one of congressman Gatti's colleagues on
the House Intelligence Committee is
democratic Adam Democrat Adam Schiff of
California we've had a long-running
dispute with the congressman on the
matter of Russia that began when he
accused us of being agents of Vladimir
Putin you're on the insulted me let me
ask you one final question can you look
right into the camera and say I know for
a fact the government of Vladimir Putin
was behind the hacks of John Podesta
absolutely the government of Vladimir
Putin was behind the hacks of our
institution and the dumb John Podesta is
not only in the know but also in Europe
okay you're not you know what your
doctor look and say well I know they did
John past and I think that Ronald Reagan
rolling Oh Ronald Reagan you're carrying
water for the Kremlin and you can't say
you're gonna have to move your shoulder
at 2rt Russian television because
because it's so dumb and you're being
duplicity I'm asking you did they hack
modesties emails and say look into the
camera and say they hack John Podesta's
he knows we know for a fact that Putin's
government did that you can't and you
know you can't you're hiding behind a
weasel word that guy's a liar and a
demagogue in case you didn't notice
though McGurn is a columnist at the Wall
Street Journal he just sort of peace
asking why congressman Schiff seems so
uninterested in whether the infamous
Trump dossier is true or the facts in
there are they right mr. McGurn joins us
tonight bill thanks coming up thanks
Tucker
so obviously I'm annoyed by Adam Schiff
because in the face of his sincere
question he accused me of being a
Kremlin agent and in effect unpatriotic
you have I think a little emotional
distance from this tell us your concerns
about his behavior as a member the Intel
committee well at a basic level the
Intelligence Committee is an oversight
committee right and also site committees
are charged with getting information
keeping tabs on the government this man
it just seems determined not to get
information and certainly not to get it
to the American people you know when the
Republicans put together their memo
outlining some of the information they
found from the FISA application and so
forth you know he was asked on CNN
shouldn't the American people see this
and he opted for the Nathan jessep
response and a few good men you can't
handle the truth I mean he doesn't trust
the American people I think you know the
bias should be toward disclosure I think
there are legitimate things that should
not be disclosed but you know we make
unclassified summaries of classified
information all the time and remember he
fought the subpoenas of Justice he
fought the subpoenas for the FBI he
fought the subpoena for fusion that
eventually led to the news that the
Hillary campaign had funded the steel
dossier so you're old enough and I am to
to remember a very different time where
the sides were kind of inverted and it
was Democrats Frank Church of Idaho for
example were arguing that the public has
a right to know at least a broad outline
of what the Intel agencies are doing
what law enforcement is doing it's our
government it's our country we have a
right to know Democrats used to say that
all the time I agreed with them when did
they stop saying that in why III don't
know I mean look to me there are two big
issues I want to know whether people on
the Trump campaign colluded with Russia
to affect the election right that's
something I want to know they also want
to know if people at justice and the FBI
are too premier law enforcement agencies
put their fingers on the scales for
political reasons remember both
candidates were under investigation of
some sort by the FBI it's extraordinary
and that the most important thing is not
prosecutions it's finding out the truth
and we have a whole lot of people I mean
when when this memo was produced and it
came out you know it had the hashtag
released the memo yeah you know
congressman ships came out and was
blaming it on Russian BOTS well you
could look at it the other way what does
it tell you when Russian bots are more
for disclosure than a than a congressman
on on the house Intel committee we've
invited him many times including
yesterday to come on and explain that
explain how he found himself basically
practicing McCarthyism yeah it's always
on the TV show saying he found more than
circumstantial evidence that Donald
Trump had colluded but we haven't seen
any of the evidence
it sounds like OJ's promises to find the
real killer you know well he won't come
on this show he hasn't been since
December 7th we're keeping track of last
year so
Bilger thank you very much for that
thanks tucker appreciate it